foreign
hey you guys here we are on the movie
retrospective once again talking about
um a stone cold classic today I think it
was probably I think it was maybe Zach
in one of the chats that like um asked
us to do this one so you know we we've
been trying to do like a lot of sort of
classic films and stuff like that and
I'm really glad that we got around to
doing this one this is Roman polanski's
Chinatown from 1974. yeah starring Jack
Nicholson yes and what's her name uh
Faye Dunaway Dunaway yes two Classics
but Jack carries this man this is a good
Jack Nicholson movies yeah I mean well
the thing about it was that the guy that
wrote the screenplay which we'll get
into in a minute uh Robert Town who's
actually considered one of the greatest
screenwriters ever
um he him and Jack Nicholson were
actually had been roommates at some
point because Jack Nicholson had been in
some movies prior to this but he wasn't
like a mega star and so Robert Town
wrote this movie like specifically with
Jack Nicholson in mind and man what a
great [ __ ]
uh private detective he makes yeah I
don't think we should spoil anything
about the movie we'll just talk about
the quality of the movie because there's
some at the end there's some reveals and
[ __ ] I don't think I think we got to
respect those yeah I mean people haven't
seen this movie that's the thing it's
it's at this point it's like I feel like
Chinatown is such a classic that a lot
of people maybe know the stuff but you
never know because you know it was a
long time ago how about this movie maybe
people huh I forgot all about this movie
you know and I was around when it came
out you know I've never seen it yeah
that was good I had seen it once but a
very very long time ago like probably
when I was a teenager and I didn't
really I remembered like a couple of the
plot tropes about in like a couple of
the reels and stuff but I didn't like
remember how it ended and the ending
specifically
interestingly even though so this movie
was actually nominated for 11 Oscars you
know the year that it came out but
weirdly the only one that it won was
best original screenplay but like I said
Robert Town Robert town I believe
um he worked on a lot of movies but he
wasn't credited so I guess he's almost
kind of like they they call him like a
script doctor I think he worked on
Godfather Godfather too like a bunch of
like classic movies and this is
considered as far as I'm aware the
screenplay for Chinatown is considered
uh one of the best if not the best
screenplays ever written and I kind of
feel like if you just watch the movie
one time I don't know if you pick up on
like what's good about it I definitely
think this is a movie that you have to
like watch more than once it's a chilled
out flick okay it's it well that might
make us make it seem like it's boring
it's not boring
it's a detective movie kind of like Sam
Spade type movies it's a period piece in
the 20s it's 30s it's actually it's
actually 1937. okay late 30s I was
thinking well yeah it couldn't have been
20. although the cars yeah yeah 30s and
um so it's a period piece and they cover
that period it looks it looks authentic
you know because there's outside shots
and everything going down the street and
a bunch of Interiors it's it's it's it
looks like you're back in time
um
the Jack Nicholson that's doing this is
the Jack Nicholson from around you know
around the pride before after The
Shining around that time yeah this is
way before way before okay because this
was 74 and The Shining was 1980. yeah
okay so he's he's Young
and he's he's in his prime you know uh
physically and he just pulls off a
really good Sam Spade kinda
hard-boiled detective you know old
school stuff it's like a Noir flick
um it's got kind of like uh if you like
The Untouchables you'd like it uh it's
that level of quality the way it's shot
and the storytelling it's kind of a
little bit like Blade Runner like
Harrison Ford and Blade Runner it's got
that good because that was supposed to
be a Noir too like detective flick it's
got that in it and if you like The
Shining you'd like this it's
Jack Nicholson right it's not Jack
Torrance
he's a lot smoother than that but you
see a lot of the you see a lot of
kubricki and kind of quality in this
with uh with with with with Nicholson
Jack's taking this second role real
seriously ladies he's real good in it
you know he's not he's not chewing up a
scene scenery like he did in Mars
Attacks or anything he's just just
he does a great job in the movie he
you're able to see exactly what
Jacqueline Nicholson's acting skills
were when he was in his prime he's good
and it's a good story
uh
he's just he was an ex-cop when he
ex-police detective or did he just
didn't know him no he had worked in
because remember that was kind of the
whole like the reason that it's called
Chinatown it's not said in Chinatown or
anything like that Chinatown is actually
just kind of like a metaphor
yeah or for Life yeah like for
corruption that's like so large that you
can't do anything about it because his
character used to be a police detective
and his beat was Chinatown yeah and the
whole thing about that was there was so
much crime going on that basically the
the police force just told him hey just
like keep your head down and don't get
involved in it because it's just like
it's too much and you don't like
understand it and all this other kind of
stuff which has parallels to how the
story of the movie plays out you know I
mean even though you don't really see
like the last scenes of it do take place
in actual Chinatown but Chinatown is
actually more like a state of mind yeah
like the futility of fighting back
against all of these like larger events
yeah now that you put it that way it
also there's a lot of parallels with
this movie and bullet bullet was like
that too yeah this has very much it's a
Noir but I want to get into like how it
differs a little bit from the classic
Noir narrative but it also has like a
very large strain of like 70s conspiracy
Thriller like The Parallax view or like
all the presidents man or something like
that there were a lot of movies like
this that came out around this time
period it just so happens that this one
is like a Noir film but it has like a
conspiracy Thriller type sensibility to
it one of the things I liked about it is
that you
is that when he's doing the
investigation you kind of don't know
what he's thinking it takes time
sometimes for you to real it's for him
to kind of come out before you can
figure out what it is he's taken what
he's what what he what he's suspicious
of you just got to see it you know it's
it's I guess it I don't know can you
just can you describe that better than
me like it
you can tell he's he's he's working on
something and he's thinking something's
going on but I always was under the
impression that he's not telling you the
audience everything that he's thinking
yeah when it comes to what he suspected
is happening I mean he will
but it like comes late sometimes it's
like he was he'd been suspected that
before right yeah you were supposed to
suspect it along with him but so he's a
little bit he's usually like a step or
two ahead of me you know I'd have to see
it again well the thing about it too is
that the reason why you know I'm not
well I won't give away the ending or
anything like that but I will say that
this is actually like a tragic story in
the way that it's unlike a lot of noir
films um even though they were very dark
and stuff like that they had kind of a
similar setup where it was like a
detective and you know who was all
cynical and everything but who you know
kind of maybe had his heart melted a
little bit or had like um or you know
the good guy kind of won out in the end
yeah this is served this movie
um is does not have that right and so
it's almost like a subversion yeah of a
lot of the classic Noir tropes like
especially like Faye dunaway's character
who is presented very much as a femme
fatale and you know the character of uh
Jake giddis who was You Know Jack
Nicholson's character he even approaches
her that way and reacts to her that way
but then you find out that that's not
exactly like what her deal is so this is
very much like a Noir but it's also like
subverted like a subversion of the Noir
genre it doesn't like end up because the
thing about it too is that Jack
Nicholson's character at the beginning
like I said because he's fresh off
Chinatown because he's very much you
know just let sleeping dogs lie he even
says that to a you know to a woman that
comes to him for help like because he
that's what he does like his detective
agency they're just like it's mostly
like Affairs and stuff and he's
basically are you sure you want to know
like you know you don't want to know
just leave he's coming back home just
leave it alone and [ __ ] like that so he
get kind of learned that while he was in
Chinatown it's like oh this is too big
for you and he just got like really
cynical and like just kept his head down
but he sort of because he gets set up in
this whole particular thing then he kind
of gets interested in in what's going on
who's behind all of this and as it goes
on the story gets bigger and bigger and
he seems to think that he's going to be
the hero of this he's going to solve
this problem but him doing that actually
ends up blowing up in his face and like
getting other people hurt yeah that's
one of the reasons why this movie kind
of reminded me a little bit of bullet
yeah in bullet the detective you know uh
the detective in that one uh he kind of
solves the case but there's limits to
what he can do the corruption's so bad
you're not he's not even sure if he won
yeah yeah it's similar like I said that
was a very very common thing in the 70s
so this is almost kind of like taking uh
you know the the characteristics of a
Noir from back in the old days like The
Maltese falcon or something like that
which by the way John Houston who plays
like the big bad in this uh you know
Noah cross is the name of the character
he that's actually
Houston that's the guy that directed The
Maltese Falcon so he's in this because
of that you know what I mean because
he's very known as like a Noir director
yeah so you know Roman Polanski who
directed this movie is like making a
call back to Classic uh Noir kind of
stuff from that era and if you haven't
seen Steve McQueen's bullet see it yeah
it's another one it's kind of like this
it's a equal quality they're both see
them both see them both they're both
good detective flicks yeah they're very
similar yeah like I said different
bullet is set in the 70s but this has
very much a 70s sensibility even though
it's clearly like seven thirteen thirty
years and this is actually like largely
based on it's not exactly based on real
stuff but it's based on a lot of the
things in here
um are based on real things that happen
like I said in LA and it's basically
you know the the plot that he uncovers
has to do with you know the LA water
wars right where you had like kind of
all of these oligarchs and they were
controlling access to water necessarily
you know um kind of cutting off water to
some areas and like diverting it to
other areas and like I think it was
actually going on it was well yeah they
know that
um farmers and crops are involved in
people's Investments and they're trying
to [ __ ] stamp out your your oligarchs
trying to stamp out their competition it
was dirty yeah and so that's very much
what's going on in this where it's just
kind of like they're denying water to a
particular area where like farmers and
stuff like to dry all the land up and
then like if all that land gets [ __ ]
up then they can buy it for really cheap
like and then go back in there and you
know let loose the water and like get it
back and then it'll be like super super
valuable so that's kind of like this big
conspiracy that that he uncovers and
it's weird because it starts out like
really small it kind of starts out as
the this woman
comes to him and says that she is the
wife of um mulray who is like the head
of the water and power and she's like um
oh I think that he's cheating on me so I
want you to like spy on him and he's
like are you sure you want to know and
everything like that and she's like yeah
yeah like money's No Object so he starts
um you know following the dude around
and it looks like he's having an affair
and so he goes around like taking
pictures and he has kind of his uh you
know his Confederates like going around
taking pictures and then like um without
him having anything to do with it but
then it gets splashed all over the media
which ruins the guy's reputation and
then the guy ends up dead
and then you have a thing where this
other woman shows up who's Faye Dunaway
and said no actually I'm the wife of
that guy I don't know who the [ __ ] that
woman was that came here before at which
point like Jake You Know Jack
Nicholson's character realizes that he's
been set up by somebody for some reason
uh you know who sent that fake woman in
here like why was I sent to go watch
that dude and like make it look like so
he's kind of being played and that makes
him mad and he wants to figure out what
the [ __ ] is going on so then like as I
said as it goes on he kind of like
uncovers this much larger conspiracy
that's going on in La about like water
rights and what all of these kind of
like rich people are doing and
manipulating the water and buying up
land and all this other kind of [ __ ] and
you know in the course of him figuring
that out there's also like another sort
of personal mystery having to do with
Faye dunaway's character and like you
know what I mean the the Widow of the
guy that ends up killed later on
so and and like I said him
it's a it's an interesting character
piece because him being like so cynical
and like not really wanting to get
involved at the beginning but
through meeting her and like through
getting
um kind of sucked into this big mystery
he almost kind of gets his
like I said he almost kind of like wants
to become a hero he wants to fix it you
know he starts to kind of like I guess
like fall in love with her and he wants
to you know fix her problems and things
like that but in the course of doing
that it kind of ends up um like I said
kind of shooting goes sideways it goes
very very sideways so he's actually
inadvertently he's a cause of a lot of
the things that he didn't actually want
to happen you know what I mean which
actually there's a line
toward the beginning where he's talking
to Faye dunaway's character and saying
about you know his old days when he was
a cop in Chinatown and they said oh yeah
they told us just go there and just do
as little as possible and so that's like
what he'd been doing and he actually
quit the force because of something that
happened like he's like well I was
trying to prevent this woman from
getting hurt and it ended up like what I
was doing to prevent her from getting
hurt ended up her getting hurt you know
what I mean so they kind of like
foreshadow everything which like I said
everything in this screenplay is
there's not um it's in in the manner of
like a lot of 70s like style conspiracy
Thrillers it is kind of like slow paced
it's quite long it's probably like two
hours and 15 minutes or something like
that but it never feels it never feels
like it's dragging though because
there's always like all of these kind of
mysteries going on and you're always
and you're always in Jack Nicholson's
shoes he's in every single scene
everything is from his subjective point
of view and the way that Roman Polanski
shot it even like shows you that like
there's a lot of shots like from over
his shoulder like looking at so you can
see like what he sees and things like
that so you're very much seeing
everything through his perspective
um and as I said it's almost kind of
like he's being manipulated by forces
outside of his control and things end up
going really really badly just because
he popped his head up and tried to make
a difference so like I said this is
almost like it's a very very cynical
movie
I believe though that the original
screenplay which is written by Robert
Town
um it had a slightly different ending
but Roman Polanski insisted on the
ending that it had which if you've seen
it is um I'm just gonna say it's not a
happy ending that's that's all I'm gonna
say about it
um but yeah and actually after it was
made and everything because I think
Robert town was kind of like didn't love
it at the beginning but then after he
saw the finished movie he's like okay
yeah well that's the way that it should
have ended you know even though
it's it's kind of a bummer it's a good
foot it is it's very it's a very good
movie it's a it's one of those movies
where particularly if you're into Noir
particularly into conspiracy theory
Thrillers from the 70s
um this is kind of like the best of both
of those things because it works as a
Noir but it also works as a subversion
of a Noir because it's kind of like not
it's playing with your expectations
about what
um you know what the tropes of that
genre are when it starts you think it's
going to be almost a black and white
movie it's got kind of like uh 30s or
Art Deco looking
um intro you go man is this gonna be
black and white so it makes you you
think you're going to see an
old-fashioned movie I mean it puts you
right back in that time here and it puts
you right back in there and it starts
it's not it's it does have that Noir
tone but it's in color and it's uh it's
a modern movie
but the pacing is kind of like an older
movie uh at times it's just a good mix
it's a good mix it's um
like those old detective movies I I
never really could watch them couldn't I
wasn't patient enough to sit through
them this one you can because it's it
moves faster than those other ones you
know I liked it and there's the the
Mysteries are a little more compelling
than some of the older ones that I
wasn't able to [ __ ] actually sit
through you know but uh so this is like
a good introduction I think to kind of
like the Noir concept yeah this one in
Blade Runner because the Mysteries going
on here like there's kind of they're
kind of like two separate Mysteries but
they're kind of intertwined you know
what I mean so there's always something
going on you know what I mean and
there's I'm not going to say there's not
a lot of dialogue in this because
there's a lot of dialogue but all of the
dialogue that's in this is necessary
there's no like [ __ ] there's no fat
in it there's nothing like everything
that said has meaning sometimes more
than one meaning
if you liked bullet you'd like it if
you'd like The Untouchables you'd like
it if you'd liked um Blade Runner you'd
like if you like The Shining you'd like
it it's it's a good flick it's really
good yeah actually if you liked um Eyes
Wide Shut you'd like it it's got some of
that it kind of stuff going on in it
um it's a good movie yeah and I'm not
sure
um I don't remember if I saw this movie
I think I did but in 1990 they actually
made a sequel to this uh called the two
Jakes and it was directed by Jack
Nicholson who also starred in it he was
playing the same character
um now supposedly Robert Town wanted to
do a Trilogy because he was gonna do
this was like his La Trilogy so
Chinatown is about water like water
rights the water wars
um the two Jake's is actually a similar
kind of story like with you know a
conspiratorial you know fighting over
control but it's oil and then there was
going to be
uh third one which I think was called
um giddis versus giddis or something
like that and that was gonna be about
land like land speculation but because
the 1990 movie the two Jake's like
didn't really do all that well
um they kind of had to scrap it but that
would have been like really really
interesting I mean it's too late now
because Jack Nicholson is like old as
[ __ ] but I mean I don't know I guess she
could still do it but I just think
that's like a really cool idea I mean I
don't
I think I saw the two Jakes but I don't
really remember that much about it
um you know so it's kind of a shame
because I kind of would have liked to
have seen but I mean at least we have
this
you know at least we have Chinatown
which is this is good enough which is
which is one of the most iconic like
American films ever made like I said you
know I know Roman Polanski he's you know
not the greatest human being but uh he's
a great [ __ ] director and this is one
of his best movies he's in this too like
but just a cameo yeah he's the guy that
uh Cuts Jack Nicholson's nose yeah
pretty nosy kitty cat
which is still like a pretty visceral
apparently I heard like the special
effect on that they said it was a real
knife they just had it kind of like
manipulated so it wouldn't cut him but
it's like if he had [ __ ] it up wrong
he would have cut his nose open like
that but that's still like a real ooh
kind of like scene but holy [ __ ] I think
that's that's probably the second most
famous scene I feel like the last the I
think the most famous scene maybe is
well just kind of that final line you
know what I mean where he says forget it
Jake it's Chinatown which is one of the
most classic like film lines ever made
because it just it just sums up the
entire yeah theme of the movie yeah like
nothing you can do about it it's like
you should have just like kept out of it
you know what I mean or none of this
would have happened essentially is what
he was saying but yeah um we watched
this on what was that on HBO Max we
watched this on HBO Max I'm sure it's
streaming uh anywhere else as well I'm
sure a lot of people that are like
really into film have seen this by now
but if you haven't
um that's why we didn't really want to
spoil it too much because it is a
mystery and it's better if you kind of
go into it not not knowing exactly
what's going on or how it's going to end
or anything like that so if you've seen
Chinatown or you know if want to talk
about it down in the comments please do
so and that will do it for this movie
retrospective we'll see you guys again
on the next one bye